Fox News host Shepard Smith completely
dismantled Donald Trump's spy gate lies
yesterday and this Friday on audience
questions we're gonna cover what would
it take for Fox News to turn on Donald
Trump and when we say that we mean aside
from the occasional voices of reason of
Shep Smith less frequently Chris Wallace
and one time I was it just one time Neil
Cavuto I think it was one time that Neil
Cavuto said something that made sense
one thing that Shep Smith has been doing
throughout the trump presidency more
than anybody else on Fox News has been
calling out Donald Trump for his lies
and that includes the Hillary Clinton
uranium one conspiracy theory a few
months ago and he did it again yesterday
and if you haven't been following
Spygate and I don't blame you if you
haven't been following it it's a sort of
amalgamation of conspiracy theories
being pushed by Trump and Rudy Giuliani
and some others ranging from Democrats
and Robert Muller are rigging the
upcoming midterms too literally there
was an FBI spy in Donald Trump's
campaign during 2016 and it's all meant
to discredit Robert Moeller's
investigation Trump yesterday sent out
an early morning tweet about some of the
stuff saying the 13 angry Democrats plus
people who worked eight years for Obama
working on the rigged Russia witch-hunt
will be meddling with the midterm
elections especially now that
Republicans stay tough are taking the
lead in polls polls capitalized
there was no collusion collusion
capitalized except by the Democrats this
is not only ridiculous but indicative of
a completely expired relationship to the
real world on the behalf of Donald Trump
Shep Smith dismantling the entire thing
on Fox News no less take a look
president Trump accusing his special
counsel and his team of a whole new set
of conspiracy theories unfounded not
based in fact or reason with no evidence
to support them the president says
backup the president says that Robert
Muller and his team are meddling in the
midterms there's nothing to support that
claim and neither the president nor the
White House has offered anything to
support that claim yet here's the tweet
right the 13 angry Democrats plus people
who worked eight years for Obama
working on the rigged Russia witch-hunt
will be meddling with the midterm
elections especially now that
Republicans state off are taught are
taking the lead in the polls good
inflection was no collusion except by
the Democrats that was the tweet the
president claims the special counsel
investigating Russia election
interference and potential collusion
with team Trump will be meddling in our
elections there is nothing to indicate
that's true as for the rest of the tweet
documents show there are people who've
registered as Democrats on the special
counsels team but Robert Muller is a
Republican and so is president Trump's
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
who appointed Muller an appointment many
top Republicans praised and the
so-called rigged Russia witch-hunt is
not a witch-hunt it has resulted in
charges against for former Trump
associates three pleaded guilty to lying
to investigators about Russia President
Trump has also claimed the feds spied on
his campaign with an informant the
president calls it spy gate Fox News can
confirm it is not Fox News knows of no
evidence to support the president's
claim that lawmakers from both parties
say using an informant to investigate a
suspected ties to Russia is not spying
it's part of the normal investigative
process I truly don't know why Shep is
on Fox News and we've speculated that
it's calculated by Fox so that when they
get called out for their sweeping bias
they can say well look we've got Shep
Smith here it's possible Shep Smith has
something on the executives there the
late great Alan Combs who of course
passed away a couple years ago is
someone I got a chance to know sort of
well when I was living in New York City
and he told me some interesting things
about Shep Smith which I've never
discussed but would not make me totally
surprised that Shep Smith may actually
have something on Fox executives there
many possibilities and I genuinely
wonder whether having Shep on Fox News
is a good thing overall right because on
the one hand we could say listen Shep
Smith on Fox is an attempt to pierce the
hyper partisan bubble that their viewers
live in the counter to that would be
isn't it sort of a waste of someone who
can tell it as it is at least
times and all it really provides is some
cover for Fox News to say here's one guy
who has a different point of view which
is called the facts compared to
everybody else on Fox News so I don't
know do you have a strong feeling one
way or the other Pat about whether it's
a net gain or loss to have Shep on Fox I
think it's a net gain for Fox to have
him on because yeah then they can say
that we play at both sides but it's
pretty obvious too that they're never
gonna put him in primetime they're not
they're not gonna mix them in with like
Hannity and Laura Ingraham and Tucker
Carlson he'll keep him his show in the
early afternoon and and that satisfies
everyone I think and the Fox News
audience still immediately calls for his
firing every time he says something like
this so it doesn't seem like he's really
getting through to too many people over
there in any case he was right there's
no evidence whatsoever that any of these
conspiracy theories are actually based
in reality the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad